- Is there something else that
you've been excited about,
like reusable rockets
perhaps, that you've seen
in the last few years?
- Yep, well the re-usability you had,
the re-usability is awesome!
(laughter)
I mean it's just the best.
Now, we have to remember the
shuttle was a reusable vehicle.
Which, the shuttle is an amazing,
as an aerospace engineer,
I mean the shuttle is sill
just the most gorgeous,
elegant, extraordinary
design of a space vehicle.
It was reusable, it
just wasn't affordable.
But the re-usability of
it was really critical
because we flew it up, it did come back so
the notion of re-usability,
I think, absolutely.
Now what we're doing with
we and all, the global we,
but with SpaceX and Virgin,
sending the rockets up,
recovering the first stages,
where if they can regain 70%
cost savings, that's huge.
And just seeing the control,
y'know, there couldn't
be a control on dynamics,
just seeing that rocket
come back and land,
- Oh yeah, that's--
- It never gets old, it's
exciting every single time
you look at it and say "That's magic".
So, it's so cool.
- To me, the landing is when
I stand up and start clapping.
Just, just the control.
- Yeah, just the, the
algorithms, just the control,
and hitting that landing, it's,
y'know, it's gymnastics for rocket ships,
but to see these guys
stick a landing.
- Pretty well put.
- Is just wonderful.
Like I said, every time I
see, y'know, the re-usability
and the rockets coming back
and landing so precisely,
it's really exciting.
So it is, actually, that's a game-changer.
We are in a new era of lower cost
and a lot higher frequency.
And it's the world, not just NASA,
many nations are really upping
their frequency of launches.